I picked something that I had been wanting
to learn more about since 1997 and just never
figured out how to do it.
You had no justification.
I mean, I've never needed justification for
anything. I think you know that about me.
I guess that's true.
I've learned that about you, yes.
You made it sound like I
drove through your front door.
This is a topic near and dear to my heart as
a former Ninja Turtle-head. So I've wanted to
talk about this for a long time and I would
love to talk to you two about it. So Nina,
out of the Ninja Turtles ripoffs, we kind of
briefly discussed before this chat, what was the
one that you kind of wanted to expound on a bit?
What was the one that you found most fascinating?
Well, the one that really grabbed my attention
is... It started running in 1990 and then it ran
until 1991. So nice long run of 52 episodes.
And it is called Samurai Pizza Cats. And
while I was Googling the many Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle spin-offs, i-
Rip-offs. No spinoffs just rip-offs.
I consider this Canon, Brian,
because it involves pizza.
I stand corrected. That's true.
Yeah.
That's what brings those universes together.
It's the pizza.
The one character across all.
Into the pizza-verse.
It's the Rosario Dawson of the Netflix,
Marvel, cinematic universes; pizza.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Into the
pizza-verse. I was entranced by
Samurai Pizza Cats, mostly because
the song for it is catchy as hell.
Samurai Pizza Cats.
The theme song, Samurai Pizza Cats. And
it also does that thing that they always
did on cartoons in the mid-'80s and early '90s
where the theme song is like two minutes long,
and it just tells you all of the characters
and what they do and what their deal is, which
is like one of my favorite things, because nobody
does that anymore. But every old cartoon is like,
every kid just sat there for two minutes and
they know who the characters are, presumably,
if they watch the show, but they get it explained
to them every time. So I assume you two...
You just drill it into their brains.
Yeah. And then they know. So are you two-
Donatello does machines.
I have to assume that you two are
familiar with Samurai Pizza Cats.
I am somewhat familiar.
I've got a passing familiarity with
Samurai Pizza Cats, but why don't you sing
us the song? Tell us about the characters.
Well, Samurai Pizza Cats was set in the fictional
town of Little Tokyo, and it is filled with
what is described as cybernetic anthropomorphic
animals. So just robots. And it has an emperor,
but he's not really in charge. There's a very
intricate plot for the leadership of the city,
going on in this children's cartoon. And so
there's a city council and it's headed by
Seymour, the Big Cheese, like his nickname is the
big, and his name is Seymour Cheese. So that's-
Very good.
I want to be clear about the order of those
things. And he's a rat, surprising no one. He has
cohorts who do his bidding, named Jerry Atric
and Bad Bird. They lead an army of crows,
which I guess is called a murder of crows,
but they probably didn't call them that in a
children's cartoon. However, there is a secret
uprising led by Big Al Dente, my favorite
character name in the show. He leads three little
robot cats who are the titular Samurai Pizza Cats,
and their names are Speedy Ceviche, Guido
Anchovy, and the token girl, Polly Esther.
But my favorite part of Samurai Pizza Cats is
those three. It's like they lead double lives.
They try to defeat the corruption of the city
council by night, but by day they run a pizza
parlor. They don't change outfits or their
appearance at all to work at the pizza parlor,
so they just look the same all the time, but
no one can figure out that they're also the
vigilantes, saving the city from corruption. And
also, the top of the pizza parlor is a giant gun,
that they use to fight bad-
Right. It's a revolver, right?
Yeah, it's a huge revolver. So there were
some controversies with this show. There
was some appropriation controversies. There
were controversies where it would name stuff
like Chuck E. Cheese, but I'm not sure it had
the rights to name stuff like Chuck E. Cheese,
so they would have to pull the
episodes from air to not get sued.
I found a really great fact on a little website
called Wikipedia, and it says citation needed,
but I need this to be true. So just let it
be true. It says that one of the writers,
Michael Arrington, sang the theme song for the
series, sang Samurai Pizza Cats. And apparently
he imbibed a little before the recording. And
so he just stumbles over a couple lines and they
left those stumbly lines in the original
recording. So if you listen carefully,
you can hear a kind of drunk guy singing
the theme song for a children's cartoon.
I'm fine with that.
Anyway, I'm going with Samurai Pizza
Cats. I want to watch every episode
of this. It's actually on Peacock, so I
might, but it's insane. Everything about it
is offensively weird and I love it. It's perfect.
Wow.
That sounds great.
Samurai Pizza Cats.
That's a good pick.
If you go watch the intro, I dare
you to not get the song stuck in
your head. It's been stuck in my head for days.
It's stuck in my head right now.
I walk around my house, just going like,
"Samurai Pizza Cats. Samurai Pizza Cats,"
like all the time now. Just
how I live. I blame the show.
How did this not take off? This is amazing,
Probably because of all the controversy
and the slightly drunk people making it.
Probably. Tom, what about you?
Drunk people making things in controversy is like
90% of what's on TLC at any given point, right?
Why is this not a bigger franchise?
True. And also frankly, some of the
great art in the history of the world.
100%. Yes. Absolutely.
But still for some reason, Samurai
Pizza Cats just didn't hit.
Tom, what was your pick for the TMNT rip
off that you wanted to talk about today?
Okay. I was really excited that we get to talk
about this because I picked something that I
had been wanting to learn more about since
1997 and just never figured out how to do it.
You had no justification.
I mean, I've never needed justification for
anything. I think you know that about me.
I guess that's true.
I've learned that about you, yes. Go on.
You made it sound like I
drove through your front door.
Not yet.
Just wait until I get my giant
roof gun, then you'll be sorry.
Sadly. At my pizza parlor. Sorry, Tom, go on.
In the second half of the 1990s, this is
probably post-the point where turtle fever,
which you brought up earlier, which I
think is just called salmonella. Right?
I was going to say, was that one of the
great pandemics of the '90s? Turtle fever?
Yeah.
I remember my mom wouldn't let me get a
turtle because she was afraid that I would
get turtle fever. So we're well past
the point where we're still color-coding
anthropomorphic animals and giving them specific
weapons at this point. I feel like children's
entertainment has kind of moved on at this point
where we're just about to start doing Pokemon.
Anyway, so there was this group of four
brothers, these independently wealthy dudes,
who decided that they wanted to get into
movies. They made a production studio that
was helpfully called Four Brothers Productions.
And they made a movie called Warriors of Virtue,
with no experience having made movies at
this point. It was this wildly expensive,
bizarre film directed by the guy that would
go on to make classics like Freddy vs Jason
and The Bride of Chucky. So that's where
the bar is right now, just to be clear.
The story is about this kid who... And I don't
know, growing up around this time, if you ever
rented a VHS from a Blockbuster or Hastings
for a kids' movie, there was almost always an
ad for this movie. It looked intriguing when I was
a kid. And then I looked into it and I found it.
I feel like I remember seeing ads for it. Yeah.
I know. For sure, I remember
the ads. I remember toys,
but I never was compelled to
actually sit and watch it.
Yeah. I feel like there were... Were
there happy meal toys or something?
Almost definitely. Yeah. I feel like they pulled
out all the stops to make this movie. It was...
The prevailing feeling I have about this
movie when I recall it is that everything,
I seem to recall, everything looks
dirty. It's dank, and there's just
these anthropomorphic kangaroos doing martial
arts. In my mind, I just smell like wet dog.
Everything looks dirty in that everything looks
like it's a community theater
production. For the most part.
Perfect.
Aside from the prosthetics, the character
makeup is incredible. It's gorgeous.
What I'm imagining is The Nightman Cometh,
but in a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles ripoff.
So most of the sets look like you're
backstage on the Nightman Cometh. It's rough.
Like a painted window. Yeah.
Very much, yeah. Also, the story, real hard
to parse. There is a kid with leg braces who
makes friends with a guy who works at a Chinese
restaurant, and the guy who works at the Chinese
restaurant tells him about vaguely Asian mythology
and the kid that sticks with him, apparently
because when the kid falls into a water treatment
plant and almost drowns, he gets transported
to a world inhabited by a bunch of colorful
characters. There's all of these weird animals.
There's a giant yak standing in the middle
of the village. Really the character
design is gorgeous. There's also the cat
from Twin Peaks. The Man from Another Place,
Michael J. Anderson was the actor's name.
Oh, wow.
But the way that they've shot him, it's a little
uncanny. He looks exactly like Andy Serkis, which
brings up a lot of questions about, did they
get Andy Serkis to play? Is this what Andy
Serkis actually looks like? And he's an actual
CGI character in real life? We don't know.
To this day, we do not know.
The bad guy is an actor named Angus McFadden.
He's from Braveheart. He's the bad guy in
that. So there's Angus McFadden, and he
is terrific to me in this because he looks
uncanny. It's uncanny how much he looks like
Ricky Gervais from back when he was in...
That was worth the wait.
I thought so.
That was pretty good.
That's good.
Okay. If you saw the trailers for
this movie as a kid, you thought,
Warriers of Virtue is going to be a movie about
kangaroos doing Kung Fu. And if you thought that,
and then you rented the movie, it turns out that
you were going to learn a virtue of your own,
which is inhuman patience. The kangaroos
don't show up until 33 minutes into the movie.
How long is the movie, total? 90?
I want to say just shy of that.
I'd be surprised if it was even that long.
They poured money into this. This is the
mid-'90s. It was a $35 million movie.
It made 6.5 million of that back,
and they made a sequel anyway.
They did?
Of course.
I think the same four guys decided that
they weren't done with the story, so they
funded it. They made a sequel to the Warriors
of Virtue, but this time, and I'm sure that
this had nothing to do with the fact that they
were doing it on a TV budget, the kangaroos in
between movies had stopped looking like kangaroos
and started looking like television actors.
Got it. Amazing. And now
I just want to watch this.
I want to say it was a sci-fi original.
It was terrific. Yeah. Yeah. Don't.
It's agonizing. It is difficult to watch.
Perfect.
Or do. Live your life. You know, I'm not your dad.
I'm running out of content here. So I
got to take what I can get sometimes.
So I've always been fascinated by
these rip offs and things like that.
I was like, I know Brian's
got a good answer. Yeah.
I mean, I don't know how good it is. I'm
just going to run through a few things. I
watched Ninja Turtles back in the day, I was a
big fan, the original run, original flavor. I
was totally into that stuff. As these other shows
were coming out at the time, I didn't think that
they were rip offs. It didn't quite click with me
that they were. I'll just read off a few that I
remember from back in the day. I noticed recently
while searching for them, one I used to watch
was Biker Mice from Mars, which, like Teenage
Ninja Turtles, is exactly what it sounds like.
Perfect.
There are these Biker Mice and they're from Mars.
Biker Mice.
That was going to be my next
question. Where do they hail from?
And now they're on earth and they ride
their motorcycles around and fight bad guys.
Cool.
Another one I remember from back then was Street
Sharks, which was actually really popular.
Were they sharks on the street?
They were literally guys turned into sharks
and they fought crime on the streets.
I was really worried it was just regular
dudes who call themselves sharks.
No, that's West Side Story. You're confused.
No, I was just worried you were just going to
say, "I'm just talking about West Side Story,
a famous rip off of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles."
But there's a famous video of Vin Diesel
at Toy Fair. Have you seen this video?
Yeah.
Nina, have you seen this?
Yeah. He had hair.
No. What?
I'm going to pull this up. Hang on.
Am I going to be frightened by his hair?
You're going to be...
Jarring?
It's just cute.
Get ready to fall in love with Vin
Diesel all over again, America.
I'm going to share that with
you. You can check that out.
America. Oh my God. He does have hair.
Yeah. And he's playing with the toys.
And he's wearing a leather vest.
Yeah.
This was for children.
It wasn't for children.
Oh my god. He's just playing with toys.
It was a presentation he was giving
at Toy Fair, which is a trade show for
retailers to come stock toys, basically. That's
all it is. He was just an actor in New York.
Yeah. But this is so pure.
It's honestly really nice, because he's a young
actor and he's trying to make a living and he's
just giving it his all, because he can. At no
point will anyone ever say that Vin Diesel doesn't
always at least give a good try. Whether you think
he's doing a good job or not, he's always in it.
He's always giving it 110%. Yeah.
Yeah. Family. So, that's street sharks. Another
one I saw when just looking things up. I saw
a commercial for something I'd never heard of
called Snailiens, which is little color coded-
Alien snails.
Snails that are aliens. And they have the
names of presidents instead of famous painters.
Nina, were you already familiar with Snailiens,
or were you just putting that
together in your head, out loud?
It's a very clever portmanteau.
I wanted to guess correctly and
I wanted the victory of guessing
correctly. So I shouted it before you could, Tom.
You did great. No, you did terrific. I wasn't
sure if you were like a hardcore Snailien stan,
from day one.
By this time next week, I
will be. Give me some time.
To my knowledge, I think that was
just a toy. There was no show or
anything associated with it, unfortunately.
Okay. Let's reboot it then.
The thing that made me really want to explore
this is a property called Stone Protectors.
And I've talked to you before, about how
fascinated I am by this. Stone Protectors was
in the '90s, an attempt on the parts of some media
executives to say, "Hey, you know what's popular?
Troll Dolls. You know who doesn't buy Troll Dolls?
Boys. Let's give them muscles and superpowers."
And so it's literally action
figures that are Troll Dolls.
Buff Troll Dolls?
Buff Troll Dolls with little jets. So all the
Troll Dolls have a little jewel in their tummies,
right? So these have jewels on
their chests because they're
stone protectors. They protect the stone.
Because they're for men. They're for little boys.
Because they're for men, cool men who are cool.
Men don't have tummy buttons.
That's right. Only on their
chest. And so I always-
That's the opposite of true, but yeah, go on.
I've always known about this
show. I've never watched it.
I finally watched a few episodes and I
am happy to report that it is moronic.
It's the dumbest thing I've ever
seen in my life. It's so stupid.
There wasn't hidden
depth to Stone Protectors. Did Charlie Kaufman cut
his teeth writing episodes of Stone Protectors?
No, no, no, no. So it's like-
Spike Jones secretly inspired by Stone Protectors.
It's like this. The original Ninja Turtles...
I went back to rewatch the first episode,
just to be like, do I just like this
because I liked it when I was a kid?
I legitimately laughed out loud a couple of
times. It's a pretty good show. It's for kids,
but it knows what it is. It has a sense of humor
about itself. Street Sharks. It's fine. It's dumb,
but it's fine. There's nothing about
it that's insulting. Biker Mice From Mars.
There's a James Bond reference in the
middle of the introduction of episode eight,
which I just sampled before we got on
this recording at random, I was like, oh,
that's pretty funny. That's pretty clever. You can
tell the people making these things care about it.
Stone Protectors is so soulless and stupid.
At one point, one of the characters is asking,
"Why do we have stones in our chest?"
The lady, the princess, who's like
their band manager or whatever. She's just like,
"That's just the way it is." Like literally,
that's just the way it is. That's a line of
dialogue that they wrote for her to say, because
they couldn't come up with anything plausible
as to why the show they made is the way it is.
Now. Brian, you're throwing a lot
of information at us very fast. You
said band manager. I can't remember. Did you
mention that they were in a rock band earlier?
Okay. So here's how it starts.
Good catch. Thank you.
Thank you. So these five dudes are in a band and
they're all terrible at music. They're in a band
and they're all awful. And only one of them thinks
that there are any good. And he's the lead singer.
Cornelius. They get zapped by a beam from another
dimension, planet, I don't know, and they get
sucked into the other planet and they get... But
before that happens, they get turned into these
ugly troll people and they get muscles and all
of a sudden, they're good at their instruments.
With their chest buttons. Yeah.
So they started out as human beings.
Yes. And then they become Stone Protectors. And
I'm going to run through the roster. I don't
fully remember all of the names, but it doesn't
matter because they're all awful. The lead singer
is Cornelius. He is a samurai of some kind. He has
like a sonic voice power thing. There's a drummer.
I don't remember his name. Does he wear...
No. He's a rock climber. Why? Because '90s.
Well, how else are you going to protect
stones without climbing on top of them first?
The bass player is dressed
like a professional wrestler.
Naturally.
Which one?
Doesn't matter.
It matters to me.
There is a keyboard player named Angus, with the
worst Scottish accent I've ever heard in my life.
And he becomes kitted out with grenades,
and his keyboards shoot lasers. And he can
make things, and it doesn't make any sense.
Give us your best Angus real
quick. Can we just get a...
I'm not going to. No.
No?
I won't. I refuse.
You can't trick him into that.
This is embarrassing enough.
I'm not going to double down.
I'm not trying to trick anybody. I'm just
asking. What does Angus sound like when he talks?
It's the worst. Why don't you do your best?
Like if he was to say something like-
Do your best.
Yeah. Why don't you do what
you think it sounds like?
Because I don't know what Angus sounds like.
What do you think he sounds like?
You can make an educated guess, Tom.
I have no idea. I've never watched Stone
Protectors. That's why we came to you,
Brian. Brian, if Angus had to say
something like, for example, "Och aye,
oh, his arse is out the windae," what
do you think that would sound like?
It sounds just like that. You nailed it.
That was it? That is bad.
Then there's... I think the guitar player
is a rollerblader, because it's the '90s.
I thought you were going
to say he's a roller blade,
like a sentient roller blade. I was
expecting you to just stop at roller blade.
Did I get everybody? Yeah.
Wouldn't be the weirdest thing.
Lead singer, keyboard, bass player,
guitar, drums. Yeah. That's everybody.
So we've got a samurai, a wrestler, a
combat keyboard player, a rollerblader.
That checks out.
A rock climber.
That all makes sense.
It's just like...
I think the makeup of the Rolling Stones was
exactly what you just described.
This does not seem weird to me.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is a crazy concept,
right? It's like Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
You're cramming a bunch of nouns together. But,
it's one unifying idea, right? This is
like, what if Troll Dolls were strong
and also rollerbladed and rock climbed
and was a wrestler and had grenades
and was a samurai? And also, I don't know.
Rollerbladed. Did I say that one? Doesn't matter.
It's the too many cooks of children's cartoons.
Did you say grenades?
Yeah. He's got grenades all on him.
What?
He's kitted out with actual explosives.
It's insane. Watching it, you can just see
the cocaine on the boardroom table, like
on the screen for all to see, just like,
"Make this show. It doesn't matter if it's good.
We got to get the toys on the shelves. Yeah. The
less money you put into it now, means the more
money we're going to make later when grandparents
are fooled into buying them because they almost
look like Ninja Turtles. Quick, get it done."
Positively.
Don't rewrite it. Don't worry
about it. Just go. So yeah.
My brother and I both really wanted, we
wanted to make a kid show called Gun owls.
It was a Ninja Turtles rip off just like this.
Only, instead of having nunchucks and samurai
swords and stuff, they all had different kinds
of guns. And the idea would be that every episode
they had to bring in a new main villain because
they had shot the one that they had last week.
You know what, Tom? It sounds like
if Stone Protectors could be made,
then I don't see why you can't
still hold out hope for Gun Owls.
This seemed like an over the top idea until I
found out that one of the Stone Protectors is
carrying around frag grenades. That's
how they're dealing with their issues.
Yeah. I'm going to pull that up.
How do you learn something
at the end of each episode,
if you're stocked with grenades?
You never need to learn a lesson.
If they had brought in that fifth Ninja
Turtle, if they brought in Venus de Milo in a
live-action series, the one that everybody hated,
and she had just had like a rocket launcher,
and that was the end of every episode.
I just dropped a picture in
our chat and you can see,
this is what Angus looks like. You can see
the grenades are clearly pinned to his vest.
Holy smokes.
Oh my God.
I'm telling you, I wasn't kidding around.
Also, is he-
Isn't that a horrifying thing to see?
Is he missing a tooth?
Yes.
Is that on purpose? What happened to him?
Is that a munitions' accident?
It doesn't matter. None of it matters.
A grenade accident. Oh my gosh.
I mean, I didn't even tell you.
His caravan ran over an IED.
They fight evil trolls. They're like
evil trolls who want the stones.
Oh, there's evil versions
of the trolls with grenades?
Yeah. Well here, I'll send you this picture.
Why's there so much to unpack here?
This is Zock. He's the evil bad guy.
He does look evil. That purple hair.
Honestly, I see a guy who's using a stick to fight
a guy who has grenades. I'm having
trouble rooting for the grenade guy.
With grenades, yeah. I actually think-
Well, the stick has magic. But I mean,
it doesn't matter. None of this matters.
You know how like in rock, paper, scissors, paper
covers rock, I think grenades cover magic in most-
They cover most things, right?
They cover almost everything.
Unless he has a magic spell that makes grenades
not grenades anymore. I don't see how he's...
And there, we found the most
useful Harry Potter spell.
You know what? I'm not here to
argue the logic of Stone Protectors.
There's the most useful Harry Potter spell.
Damn it.
The spell that makes grenades not
grenade anymore. Boom. We did it.
Twelve episodes late, but we got it.
So all I can say about Stone Protectors is
that it's absolute dog s---, so don't watch it.
That's good. Cut.
And that's the end of that one. Thanks for
watching. Please hit like and subscribe so
you don't miss a single video, and tell
your friends and leave a nice comment.
Don't be mean. We read all the comments.
Please don't be mean to us. Thank you.